[Música]
a psicanálise é a possibilidade de
construir novos caminhos
todos os sábados eu pego uma cadeira de
praia e vou à praça da alfândega escutar
pessoas pessoas que têm histórias
dificuldades desejos sofrimentos mas que
não têm condições de acessar um lugar
discuta nos bairros nobres da cidade
onde a maioria dos consultórios estão
penso que todos nós deveríamos nascer um
direito assegurado o de falar e ser
escutado cada um ace de um jeito
uns nascem sufocados enrolado no cordão
umbilical outros nascem chorando
alguns berrando mas todos nascem com uma
história uma não várias
temos diversas versões de nós mesmos no
mínimo duas uma que nos é contada e uma
outra que vamos construindo enquanto
vamos desenrolando e cortando o cordão
umbilical
qual é a tua história qual é a tua
versão
eu lembro da minha vem de uma pequena
cidade do interior onde a maioria das
pessoas se conheciam e um tempo para o
outro não com veloz com o tempo da
cidade grande
vim para porto alegre com 16 anos e um
dia caminhando pela saldanha observando
o empurra empurra o corre corre das
pessoas a buzinas dos carros eu pensei
se eu caí aqui nessa calçada
ninguém vai me juntar o meu sentimento
era de total solidão desamparo
quantas vezes vocês já se sentiram assim
sozinhos e desamparados
eu precisava e queria de alguém que me
escutar se que me juntasse eu tive
eu tenho alguém que me juntou e me
ajudou a encontrar o meu lugar na cidade
grande que mostrou que o lugar do meu
desejo era também escutando pessoas
juntando pessoas através da psicanálise
isso fez com que eu entendesse a
importância eo poder transformador de um
espaço de escuta nem autorizei a ser
quem eu queria ser
e aí construindo a minha história com
caídas e andanças
foi quando peguei um avião e fui a são
paulo
descobri que existe amor em são paulo
existem profissionais éticos engajados
sensíveis ao momento em que nós estamos
vivendo o que eles fazem eles levam a
psicanálise às ruas eles terão eles
construíram uma ponte bonita entre a
psicanálise ea saúde pública entre eu e
vocês
foi numa manhã fria e cinzenta na praça
roosevelt no com um coletivo de colegas
psicanalistas que descobriu que eu
queria que poderia fazer da minha vida
eu queria dar continuidade a essa ponte
queria escutar pessoas nas ruas queria
que as pessoas pudessem ter a
possibilidade de encontro potente e
pudessem ressignificar suas histórias
suas vidas e abrir novos caminhos
de volta a porto alegre
nasci psicanálise na praça como uma
resposta a esse momento político e
social difícil em que nós estamos
vivendo
foi por um instante onde eu pude me
deixar tocar pela violência do país que
vão sair da bolha e pude questionar o
que mais eu poderia fazer além do que eu
vinha fazendo pra amenizar a dor a dor
das pessoas ea minha própria e em
relação ao momento em que nós estamos
vivendo a psicanálise saúde mental tem a
ver
idade com autonomia impossibilidades
sofre-se pelo excesso de adaptação de
conformação pelo silenciar dos nossos
desejos
vamos deixando de ser quem realmente
somos por nos sentirmos coagidos
violentados aprisionados é
impossibilitar a adi de construir novos
caminhos
um dos sábados de atendimento
tivemos a possibilidade de conversar com
o senhor que estava passando por lá se
deparou com o nosso trabalho e que as
informações
nós perguntamos se ele sabia o que era
psicanálise
fomos ensinar e aprendemos com ele ele
disse
a psicanálise é a possibilidade de
construir novos caminhos e é isso é a
possibilidade de transformar a história
que nos é contada na nossa própria
história é sermos protagonistas da nossa
existência
a psicanálise tem como premissa a escuta
do inconsciente tem um dever ético com a
escuta do desejo do sujeito com resgate
da palavra
esses dias eu estava lendo um artigo e
me deparei com a seguinte frase quando a
palavra honda conta da experiência é no
um desejo fica em carne viva e eu aqui
diria à flor da pele quando não há
espaço para a palavra para a metáfora é
no corpo que o sofrimento aparece no ato
na repetição na automatização o nosso
trabalho vai no contra fluxo da
automatização da repetição é a
possibilidade de resgatar sujeito
pensantes políticos desejantes autores
das suas próprias histórias
todos os sábados meus colegas e eu
trabalhamos lá
de forma pública aberta e gratuita
escutamos pessoas nos escutamos
construímos encontramos uma maneira
possível de mostrar que existem outras
formas de cuidado e que elas não têm
nada a ver com institucionalização mais
e mais hospitais psiquiátricos e sim uma
cadeira de praia uma escuta em uma
palavra tem a ver com o desejo com
disponibilidade tem a ver com encontros
com coletivos com sensibilidade o mês
que vem para um ano que nós iniciamos
nosso trabalho desde o nosso início
houve um número enorme de pessoas que
tinham interesse em serem ouvidos
o que mostra que há um desejo de clínica
que há um desejo discuta dezenas de
pessoas são atendidas todos os sábados
pessoas que vão em busca de um lugar
discuta e de um lugar para suas
esperanças solidão e desamparo pessoas
que vêm de diversos locais e que contam
com o psicanálise na praça para tratar
os seus próprios lugares para viverem as
suas próprias histórias
por isso que o psicanálise na praça está
aqui em porto alegre uma praça central
com o intuito de subir furos num sistema
que nos aprisiona que não nos permite
pensar que não nos permite questionar
que não nos permite ser seres diferentes
somos convocados o tempo todo a sermos
perfeitos não falharemos não errarmos
não sentir nos sentirmos medo
vocês sentem medo vocês falam sobre os
medos de vocês
precisamos o tempo todo dar resposta
certas imediatas resolutivas acreditamos
no ideal inatingível
precisamos ser os melhores os mais
bonitos os mais inteligentes mais os
mais precisamos ter mais acreditamos e
compramos essa idéia
pagamos caro por ela nessa busca pela
perfeição
abrimos mão do que realmente nos
interessa dos nossos principais desejos
perdemos e nos deixar tocar de ser
tocados ao invés do toque
escolhemos o trote nunca fomos tão
conectados e ao mesmo tempo tão sozinhos
a organização mundial da saúde divulga
que a cada 40 segundos uma pessoa se
suicida no mundo
se o mundo não está pedindo socorro
então não sei o que mais será preciso
pra que a gente possa escutar escutar
que essa forma de viver que nós
escolhemos mata escutar que saúde mental
ela existe e que pessoas adoecem e
morrem por não serem escutadas ou por
serem silenciados ainda hoje
acreditamos em pílulas milagrosas para
dar conta do sofrimento pessoas ao invés
do nome recebem diagnósticos rótulos que
levaram consigo serão parte das suas
identidades
é muito comum na praça nas clínicas nos
consultórios chegarem pessoas que antes
mesmo de dizer seus nomes se apresentam
através dos seus diagnósticos
oi eu sou bipolar
eu sou tbh eu sou borderline
eu sou doente e o que mais você é o que
tem por detrás desses diagnósticos
desses sintomas desses medicamentos
quem é você
somos responsáveis por essa venda
frenética de medicamentos e diagnósticos
sem o mínimo de de cuidado rotulamos
pessoas
transformamos pessoas em sintoma
estamos impossibilitados de sonhar
devido à quantidade de rivotril que
tomamos para dormir
somos anestesiados
somos treinados a não sentir muitas
vezes buscamos por caminhos
aparentemente mais fáceis mais rápidos
mas que nos deixam inertes a nossas
histórias que não possibilitam que nós
possamos nos apropriar da nossa história
e fazer algo diferente
a praça é um convite a esse desvio de
rota é um caminho diferente do que nós
estamos acostumados lá o nosso conceito
ea nossa visão de saúde a outra tem mais
a ver com palavras escutas e tempo lá
o sofrimento é escutado o que mais será
preciso acontecer para que nós possamos
nos escutar ligada
[Aplausos]